22 winners all under age 20 $100,000 to
drop out of school and pursue our big
ideas it's time to move to San Francisco
and get to work who will make their
dreams come true this is Team Technorati
I'm working on software to help
developers monetize their applications
I'm working on improving the decoders
and hardware in our prosthetics creating
new computer interfaces that use your
sense of touch educational games
revolutionize the satellite development
industry and make healthcare more
transparent and efficient I'm working to
cure cancer
my entire life from East Coast to West
Coast a fitness the biggest change is
gonna be waking up every morning without
a need to do this on my own and that's
totally different from you know for the
past 20 years where it's been like wake
up at this time go to school at this
point this is just a totally free
experience taking a fellowship was a
very difficult decision for me because I
only had one more year of school left my
parents were not happy about me dropping
out they told me I was an idiot
in their generation if you didn't go to
college then you weren't going to find a
job they're definitely frigging out
there hoping that I quit the fellowship
early they're like hoping that by the
end of summer I just like to go back to
school like that an affinity sign in
birds and then there's our strength I'm
hoping that it will remind me to stay
strong and follow my dreams as cheesy as
it sounds yeah I'm basically like
canceling my housing for next year
because I don't think we'll go back
school that was like one of the symbolic
steps again left my previous life behind
and excited for the future right now my
project involves working in healthcare
and making action it will change in it
my larger dream would be to be doing
something that I love and find meaning
in life that is why I chose to take the
fellowship this is a wonderful thing for
kids who are incredibly self driven but
between 90 and 95 percent of startups
fail what actually are these kids being
prepared for down the line there are
many reasons one goes to college that
have nothing to do with the content of
what's being taught
the idea of dropping out of school is
controversial but I know I'm making the
right decision my friends kept on joking
with me that I was going from one frat
to another I was like these kids are
very very scientifically minded they're
all absolutely brilliant three months of
living in a house with 12 plus imagine
how much thinking is going to get done
imagine how much tangible progress I
think what I think I see you I think I
see you are you on the phone yes
hey what's going on hey you want some
you know I have no idea wrong dining
room table there's some bedrooms Wow
second kitchen not a bad has to be Wow I
was actually really confused where it
was uh this looks kind of rundown maybe
I should've moved here and then we went
in and it was amazing my name is Tom
courier I'm a 2011 Co fellow and I run a
company called campus which is a network
of community houses so this house a
little bit different than our other ones
because it's just steal pose but I think
the interesting thing that we're doing
in campus is recreating that same like
atmosphere of like an intellectual vibe
you can have these like interesting
conversations that you do as in college
but in your home and because of this
location on like 18th and mission we
wanted to make it like have sort of an
edgy vibe these are two bedrooms I
believe they are both available right
now
if you guys want choose your rooms go
for it you know good first yeah that one
seems actually pretty nice yeah it seems
this is my you
I guess the next three months I got this
this is my lucky show trying to make it
feel more like we're gonna go eat now
a lot of change super-fun
excited and scared at the same time yeah
you know tune in to the next episode of
teen Technorati when our orientation
hits us with a big reality check and be
sure to subscribe to the wired Channel